[Music]
my name is welcome to on the next shelf
[ __ ] Friday who would have thought
pence actually pulled it off anyway I
created Fridays with PewDiePie
I think it's been no 1 and a half year
now since the first one and I did it
because I wanted to get in touch with
you brothers I wanted to acknowledge you
in whatever freaking way and I thought
what better way to do that then to
actually talk to you bros so we're gonna
do this on omegle and i'm gonna share
with you bros and it's gonna be awesome
there we go who are you calling
that's good it's really thank you thank
you
oh that's right I'm glad to hear that I
don't believe that
oh I can't believe it either
[Music]
[Applause]
I think so yeah the guy I was proving to
myself and I was like cuz she was on
your Twitter and she said oh my god he's
gonna be on omegle and I'm sitting there
like okay now she's gonna look at a
bunch of dicks and I'm gonna beautify
Hey because I feel like they make us
unhappy which every detail you rip out
you don't have to say that you both make
me happy that's all I need
[Laughter]
I'm not gonna get naked jeez I'm good
I'm flattered scare you oh yeah yeah
[Laughter]
you're still on here hoping if I you're
the you're the one looking for digs
aren't ya gonna be nice there we go
[Music]
fine go ahead and next me if I can sure
that's all so if you're really good
that's a really awesome
[Music]
are you okay there yeah nice to meet the
other speakers don't there's no need to
be speech not you the main I'm finding
the way who's that huh hey toad I made a
drum a lot of things that you came have
see that have you seen how many
dinosaurs and no other animals are
looking for you no I had no idea
dinosaurs is better I am the real PFI
mother how's it going man all right
that's cool that's cool
where are you from
really that's hope III nail the Romanian
don't worry it's close to Italy right
hey how's the guy
sorry you want a picture and give you
the best picture ever what are you
cooking it's not for me
like am i tripping balls right now
what about both sorry the best song I
have ever heard it's all thanks to you
oh my god say hi hey how's it going I'm
so happy I see you I'm glad I see you
thing without you you you always make my
day are you buttering me out here are
you jenna Marbles I think are you the
real one oh wow I'm glad you finally
found me it's nice to meet you um I just
want to thank you for writing up my face
when I'm sad because no need to thank me
ah that is really sweet do you have any
more papers can I say I love y'all
really uh-huh
thank you they make me that is Sookie Oh
[Laughter]
brofist that's awesome thank you so that
was that was that I hope you bros
enjoyed it was all I honestly was
enjoying it as much as you bros because
for me it's really hard to realize that
there are actually so many or at least
people out there who find a lot of joy
in watching my videos and that's crazy
for me that I can barely understand it
myself so it makes me really really
happy to chat with you bros it's really
awesome man so yeah stay awesome thank
you for watching and we're gonna end it
with the brown face
hey comes
[Music]